building self-confidence develop
self-confidence building confidence one
success model the best what sublimation
7 I believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today let's learn one
of the most common rules that successful
people follow build confidence also if
you want to know what Michel Jarre a
diamond - and others have to say about
confidence and excellence
check out my 254 series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you
any morning video for free now you build
your confidence the link to join are in
the description good luck most people
believe that confidence comes from past
success and that's not accurate I was
reminded this morning of a question I'm
often asked how do you eliminate fear
from your life you know one thing you
have to really never do is compare
yourself to other people absolutely
that's the one thing you can't do with
judge the success to someone else's
[Music]
I think the first key in building
self-confidence it comes from a
foundation of something people don't
talk about which is keeping promises
that you actually make to yourself
in other words self-confident people
really are self trusting people so they
have this habit over time of when they
tell themselves they're going to do
something they actually deliver on it if
you stack up those wins over and over
again if you say I'm gonna get up at a
certain time in the morning I'm gonna go
to the gym I'm gonna make a certain
amount of phone calls or I'm gonna eat a
certain way if you begin to keep those
promises you make to yourself you begin
to build that trust within yourself that
you can rely on you and that's really
what self confidence is and so typically
in first of all they don't tell you this
that really starts with keeping the
promises that you make to you and that's
the foundation all confidence is built
on were you confident before soccer or
is football what brought you confidence
no no before soccer because from the
area where I came from you need it to be
tough I mean it was a rough neighborhood
I like it from his paradise people call
it ghetto I call it paradise because I
feel I feel home I feel I can be myself
even if I'm doing that now also but in
that area it was like you don't ask for
respect you take your respect that is
the the attitude was you don't ask for
let's say signature when I go back there
now they don't ask for picture they take
the picture so that was the style that
was the attitude and and you needed to
show that you could stand up for
yourself and and be their dominant so
that came from there
then the football was just a thing I
would like to do we like people who say
I've got something to offer the world
and it's very it's people are very
reassured by confidence you know all
scared that we're gonna come across as
arrogant but if you're on a fly and you
hit turbulence you want a confident
pilot if you're sick wouldn't you like
it really covered a daughter got off I'm
the best doctor in New York I'm gonna
make you better I don't wanna go as well
I don't want to brag you know I'm sort
of okay sometimes but you know he's
better than me
we don't want our kids teacher to go
well I'm not the best you know I have
good days we want to go I'm the best
teacher and I'm gonna give you back your
kid in a year's time rate radiating
confidence and talent you know we pay
for that and yet was so scared of saying
I've got a gift I've got a skill this is
what I'm good at and one of the greatest
hang-ups that people have is the belief
in themselves they they suffer from
something called self-doubt many years
ago I read something it was by Ralph
Waldo Emerson it was this essay on
self-reliance that's what we want to do
we want to rely on self and in that he
said there would come a time in every
person's education when they realized
that envy is ignorance and imitation is
suicide so many people look at someone
that's doing very well possibly in the
same field they're in and envy them do
you know what that's saying that's
saying I don't know that I have the same
mental faculties you've got I'm drawing
on the same potential that you're
drawing on there is only one mind I
don't know that so I'm gonna envy you
thinking you can do something I'm not
able to do the truth is if you can do it
I can do it
envy is ignorance it's not knowing that
and he said imitation is suicide do you
know that nothing in this universe would
move in the precise order it moves and
your absence that's true everything in
the universe is essential you take any
part away from anything it's not
complete and everything in the universe
moves in a very precise way so do you
see we shouldn't even want to be like
anybody else because we are unique we
are truly unique there's something like
about us said you'll never find in
another person were unique and we've got
the godlike ability to think now what is
self-doubt self-doubt is the opposite of
self-confidence
confidence comes from understanding like
I would imagine you're competent you can
drive your car in fact you're so
confident that you'll be talking to
somebody on the phone you'll get in the
car you'll start the car you'll Drive
and you'll drive maybe four or five
blocks not even be unaware of what
you've done it's all done automatic your
concentration is on the conversation
you're on now when you first got in a
car you couldn't do that
the car was probably jumping all over
the place and you thought you'd never
learned how to drive it but you learned
how to drive it now you're quite
confident you're confident that you can
get dressed when you get up in the
morning when you're a little boy or
little girl you couldn't do that good to
be taught to do it well you know self
confidence comes like all confidence
that comes with knowledge and the more
you study you the more you understand
who you are the more confident you'll
become in your ability to do whatever it
is you're doing and you'll know that if
you like confidence in an area it's
because you liked information in that
area never doubt yourself and when you
do understand that the cause of that
doubt is not lying within you it's in
wrong thinking it's you not
understanding who you are study yourself
self study will develop self confidence
and self confidence eliminates self
depth every fight you bring a different
personality Wow because styles make
fights everybody don't have to stay
style and I know me I'm the most Awkward
fighter in the division you paint I
Zafira paka later than you see you may
see
yeah you know that's what they'll make
it an intriguing fight because our
spouse is so crazy it may compliment
each other you guys never know you know
but unfortunately think about theory
that he don't have power and I think
there's a possession of power is real
you know it's very real sometimes scares
me and I'm the one possesses it I don't
know when I'm gonna get I'm gonna get
you and when I do old boy I know baby
good night confidence and not giving up
is them it makes you so lean like the
don't give a factor that makes it way
you don't care what people think you
never feel like you're being judged you
never want to be a part of a crowd and
you just you know you just feel this
about the way you feel about things you
know and then also you got swag you know
you just you just do what you want
regardless of what people think and it
feels good I remember doing a photo
shoot my first year right before we
launched and they took a studio down
here to something called the Polaroid
studio I don't know if it still exists
these big Polaroid shots that they take
this size to put up budget on billboards
and stuff and the person the marketing
people were in Los Angeles and this
marketing guy sent his son was about 26
or 27 dressed the part you know who
looked perfect and he was sitting there
and going something like this trying to
do something and then he said to me no I
don't think you should wear that I think
should wear this color and I think you
should move and I said to him you know I
have food in my refrigerator older than
you are
and I've managed to get by knowing what
my good side is people are really I mean
I'm not a glam person so people are
really interested in the glamorous side
the unglamorous side they're just happy
they get me vertical if they get me
vertical they should be advocate so what
you get at age 52 coming in even to a
new business is if you've had a good
career you come in with confidence and
that's what it's all about
that's what business is all about
confidence you you know the song says
you can be a hero or a zero and the
difference is confidence and if you have
created a portfolio for yourself even in
your own head that you are really
special and you know your business and
nobody knows whatever part of that
business that you do better than you do
that gives you confidence I knew nobody
knew more than I did about family court
and about judging a lot of people I mean
I only guess one or two answers on
Jeopardy
so you have some idea of my academic
credentials but nobody knew how to be a
tactician in the court better than I did
understanding the mechanics of
confidence is really a great
understanding and so if we unpack how
confidence works it's really actually
pretty simple confidence comes from one
place and really one place only most
people believe that confidence comes
from past success and that's not
accurate it comes from what you say to
yourself and so at any given point in
time we're having a conversation we're
having a dialogue with ourself and if
we're saying things that are beating
ourselves up it might get us good it
might you might get good at something
but you might not enjoy who you are when
you arrive there so at any given point
in time the dialogue that you have with
with yourself or with myself that what
we're doing is we're speaking in ways
they're either building confidence or
destroying confidence so confidence
comes from what you say to yourself and
becoming aware and mindful of your inner
dialogue is really at the center of
being able to grow to be able to develop
to be able to pursue potential and it's
a skill that we can teach it's a skill
that we can develop and if we have a
better sense of it we can guide our own
minds towards those conversations that
build so when we are asking people to
increase their awareness of their own
thoughts great now what do we do with it
it makes sense that we want them to
guide towards a positive direction but
that's not always intuitive and easy
once you know we're familiar with our
own patterns in our mind and sometimes
it really takes a coach to coach how we
think the coach properly to adjust our
own thoughts and or a parent when we
hear our children or the athletes that
we're working with and we hear how
they're thinking about something and we
have a grounded perspective in life we
have we can recognize it we can hear
that oh that's not a great way to think
about something then we can take a
moment and take a beat if you will and
help them think about it in a different
way and that's perspective shifting it's
giving them a very specific way to
perspective shift the way that they see
themselves in the world everyone has
what's inside them call the conference
accounts and here's the scary thing at
every moment you're either helping or
you're hurting your confidence there's
no in-between every decision you make is
either helping the account or hurting it
and every accomplishment and everything
you've done up to this point is because
of that account so I didn't realize that
a lot of things I was doing whether it
was sleeping in or validating or making
excuses they were hurting my confidence
and if you don't have confidence you're
always gonna find a way to lose in
entrepreneurship so you always got to
understand how important confidence is
and protect it at the highest level and
how you how do you build confidence
well confidence is just certainty right
what's the number one reason people
won't leave corporate to go to
entrepreneurship
they're scared because they
what at their other job they have
certainty it's like well the paychecks
coming in this new economy the only
certainty you have is the confidence in
yourself and your ability to make it
happen so you have to create certainty
for your life and business by doing your
due diligence by studying by reaching
out the high level people and by making
sure that you have an identity that
whatever you say your actions follow
because when you get results
that's the often an alternate confidence
booster what was your first reaction
when you read Tracy Flick and saw what
she was gonna do it I have to do this
part I have to write and I remember
going in I read the script and I just
thought it was amazing and then my
boyfriend time Ryan said have you seen
sis and Ruth and I hadn't seen since and
Ruth so we were at Sundance and he had
seen an end during Lourdes narro Laura
Dern and it was it was called meet Ruth
Stoops and then they then it was out
Xander Payne's first full-length feature
and I saw it and y'all if you haven't
seen that movie it is so good she and
it's it's classic Alexander Payne where
it's middle of America but they're
dealing with both sides of abortion pro
rights and pro-choice and you know and
all that stuff and then it's it's just
great and I was blown away and then I so
I went in to meet with him and I just
looked at him and he said hello he
always wears a suit on Tuesdays I know I
one day it was because he was wearing a
suit and hello and I said I just wanna
let you know I'm the right person with
this part you can cast somebody else but
you'll be wrong oh that's so Tracy Flick
all right I don't even know why I did it
I was just like so in the character and
about a week later I got the call on I
got the part
I feel like a lot of the times people
auditioned and I know this is a
reflector so it's important for I'd say
this to actors all the time people just
want to be told what to do you know
sometimes they have so many decisions to
make they just want the decisions to be
taken away from them and just to go give
me the ball I'm not gonna disappoint you
I promise and I'm gonna work to the best
of my ability and I'm gonna work hard
for you you know and sometimes that just
such a relief to someone who has to
answer 200 million questions a day
you're there to make their life easier
yeah I was like I got it don't worry
about it I got it I'm gonna special
bonus clip from Dean grunts you'll see
on how to protect your confidence and I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the three-point landing
question sign the move from just
watching another video to take an action
in your life for business and if you're
feeling bold leave your answers in the
comments below here we go question
number one
how will you commit to building your
confidence number two what can you do
right now today to get started on it and
number three who will hold you
accountable to stayin consistent you
have this concept of protect your
confidence I've never heard anybody say
it like that before
why is that so important well because I
think I mean in all the big decisions
you've had to make along your way have
you ever made a good decision when your
confidence was down once like can you
say I walked in my head was down your
physiologies changed you're like a
little nervous like you just don't make
good decisions when your confidence is
down and I don't think it's like we're
either confident or not confident I
think it's like if confidence is a
hundred percent if our confidence is
ninety five percent we play smaller I
know with me like the big opportunity's
come if I'm not in that like space I'm
like you know what guys let's just let's
hold let's not like I won't make smart
decisions so I think I think we have to
do everything in our power to protect
our confidence if you want to learn from
Tony Robbins and how to create massive
confidence check out the link there
right next to me I think you'll enjoy
that video continue to believe and I'll
see you there I know the way you move to
some extent I know the facial
expressions the gestures the way use
your body
and it's all consistent with the fact
that human beings